I just always knew I just always knew
one day that I'm gonna be doing this I
knew and eventually I just went to one
of the managers and I was like I have to
have the song doing what you want means
moving forward with the way you feel I'm
21 so I'm gonna live my life like I'm a
21 year old I'm gonna dress like I'm a
21 year old she's a Barbadian singer and
songwriter with sales exceeding 200
million records worldwide she's one of
the best-selling artists of all time
she has an estimated net worth of two
hundred and thirty million dollars
she's Rihanna and here is my take on her
top ten rules for success coupe number
one is my favorite and make sure to
stick around all the way to the end for
some special bonus clips I always loved
music I always loved it um and then I
will start singing along and before you
knew it I wanted to be that person so
bad that I would live saying or dance or
look in the mirror perform for my
friends or cousins and I just always
knew I just always knew one day I'm
gonna be doing this I knew well the
first time I heard umbrella
I just knew how much I loved the song I
mean I thought I had one of the most
original songs of any song that I've
ever heard thus far and I just
especially the ones that are recording
in it I just I was like I have to had
this one I have to hit everybody wanted
it right wanted well I didn't know that
at the time at the time they were like
okay you can have this song you know
whatever I was like I have to have it
and that's what he says I knocking hold
on a second because this person was is
listening that person's listening and
eventually I just went to one of the
managers and I was like I have to have
this song this is mine now
I basically was like I'm gonna fight you
if I don't have this off well how social
media affects the way that you make
music
do you consider feedback from fans
absolutely big-time like my friends
definitely have an impact on through and
music what I do like it still comes from
me and I still like to show them new
things but I I always want to make sure
that you know I have to pay attention
yeah they say things that you need to
hear look they're out there in the world
they're not in the little box here they
know what's going on and and you will be
stupid to be so oblivious to what
they're saying you have to pay attention
every album for me has been a natural
step in my growth it has displayed the
the different steps in my career and
everyone happens to be better than the
previous one and for me that's the most
important thing just making sure that
every time you do something you do it
better than you did it before and those
we might not even want to listen to
music or watch my videos for instance
from pon de replay to Russian Roulette
it's not even the same person it's not
even the same person but yeah I don't
know anyone who has been the same person
at 17 that they were at 21 I think a lot
of people think when that them doing
what they want
means doing what everybody else doesn't
want and it's not that doing what you
want means moving forward with the way
you feel and living your truth and a lot
of the times you'll find common ground
with people sometimes there are a lot of
people you won't find that agree with
you but it has to be your your truth
because that's the only way well it's
definitely the ultimate dream for me
because I always dreamt of doing it so
yeah it could it could be the ultimate
dream but know that there's a lot of
hard work that people don't see a lot of
toil toiling at night you know a lot of
sleepless nights a lot of traveling and
some stuff you don't want to do but you
just do it for the love of it so if you
want to do it for fame or money forget
it
stop now but if you want to do it for
the love of it keep keep on going
everyone has their own definition of a
role model for me I'm twenty-one so I'm
gonna live my life like I'm a 21 year
old I'm going to dress like I'm a 21
year old I know I have a five year old
found at home but I can't live my life
like a five-year-old because I'm not
five but at 21 it for a 21 year old to
see the way I can see the way address
that's fine and I can only be a Rihanna
model because that's who I am
I can't be I can't please everybody it's
too hard
Raquel wants to know if it's hard to
remain you with all the success at such
a young age um no I I would say it is
very it can be very easy easy to be led
astray or caught up and sucked into the
fam and the bright lights and everything
being great and you know it can be easy
to do that but I have great people
around me and a lot of people that I've
known since my childhood yeah
um a lot a lot of people like trust my
big brother is jzj bran and tata lake
they're my backbone and at this point i
mean super good hands with them and they
keep me grounded they keep me in check
my mother is still my mother yeah and
she also checks me on the Reg yeah yeah
on the Reg I just had a dream I had an
idea I knew what I wanted to do and this
is what I was going to do all I wanted
to do is make music internationally you
know I'm in Barbados it's an unrealistic
goal you know you're a small little
island away from the United States what
has been Jays best advice to you in the
beginning of my career I remember on the
replay I started doing really well and
he came up to me at a showcase and he
said you must be a really great person
because great things keep happening for
you don't ever change who you are
always remain humble the same and it
kind of rings in my ear that every day I
hear that and it stuck with me and I
have a lot to be grateful for
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because Christina swagger
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do I also love to
know which of Rihanna's top ten rules
had the biggest impact on you and why
leave it in the comments and I will join
in the discussion I also want to give a
quick shout out to tishanna thank you so
much to China for buying my book for
those of you who want to change at a
shadow in a future video make sure to
pick up a copy of the book and then
email in your seat so we can keep track
thank you guys so much for watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon
I can't tell you where I see myself in
five years but I can tell you that I
will work my best to be the most
successful artist I can be in five years
what do you want to be remembered for
when you're like you know older lady
you're about to retire like what is it
thing
remember this Rihanna remembered as
being the artist from the Caribbean who
came here and made it admitted
internationally
just remember it's me because I am
treating my music and I just want people
to realize that and appreciate me for
that
okay Jam if you can name a planet what
would it be call this is the most
ridiculous question I've ever heard what
if I could name a planet I would just I
would call it gems planet because I
don't see any reason to mess around and
be unclear with what's gone on I was
allowed to name a planet so I'm gonna
call it Jim's planet I will probably
name it sha it's become sort of a
language of sorts between my sister and
I her name is Jen which turned into
shock and how do you spell that
JH eighty that's how it is my phone oh
my god I've gone sha haha without it
everybody's as that I like that it has
meaning sha Rihanna on your planet
what would the main rules be free shoes
for everyone it's good plan always any
kind and ice cream tons of ice cream you
can only eat ice cream that's the only
food I'm gonna have y'all you need a
good health care plan on that but you
will have a bag of ice cream and no
diabetes what that's not logical now oh
and no yeah well there's more than what
you can't what you can't get your size
you can't gain weight I don't know about
this but I don't have to move here I
have my own planet what three things
would you take with you from Earth to
your planet I would take Todd my partner
I would take Otis my white dog and I
would take Rufus my Shih Tzu hey
and the rest of you can piss off blood
three things would you take Shaw uh-huh
because she can pretty much facilitate
every other thing that I need my iPod my
iPod speakers what skill or talent would
you like to learn to whistle I can't
either
really I can't I'm very surprised I
musicians aren't much better so do what
I'm sorry you know what you know what I
don't even mean that because I consider
myself my own level of musician and what
I choose to learn how to what do you
think Rob Thanks
I just don't know I think you can no you
can't it's one of those things
have you tried hard yes and it sounds
just like that see you won't even do it
nope that's probably wise what secret
talent Katie you teach the boo I get the
impression they don't know like they
would not know what a piano was if they
saw it like they'd be like what does
this used for and so I want to say I
could teach him to play the piano
because I do play like you do I do
speaking of musicians I know and I can't
whistle
uh-huh-huh I didn't I took it back as
soon as I said I was just surprised I
always felt like do you know how often a
script calls for an actor to whistle
it's a frequent that is really good to
know that I would have never guessed
did I play yeah cuz you don't think I
have an ounce of rhythm what
what's the judgment you that is really
mean no no no thanks no you're right I
put words in your mouth but you're so
great at acting yeah that I better
picture you have a daddy don't buy
another absolute absolutely thank you no
I changed that you weren't a sweet